欢迎收听赵华语股获载第1134集
今天是2026年的7月7号
今天有一点七七股灾
七七股变
说有什么事呢
似乎也不能说是有什么国际性非常严重的大事
早上一看是什么
三星公布了财报
三星公布财报不错
第二季的获利大增19倍
可是韩古一开盘三星先崩
韩古一样崩到暂停交易
糟糕 台股就不太妙了
不过我们台股今天一开盘还撑了半场
中场开始下跌 跌 跌 跌
最后跌超过1000点
体感温度非常的不好
因为我们看到很多的热门族群
例如说被动元件 国具华星科都跌停
细晶圆 环球晶跌停
连最强的所谓的功率元件
今天也有向台半跌停
状况好像有点戚风苦雨
那如果看长的家数
长的公司
其实就是很零散
没有族群性之外
可能还像什么生技股啊
一些就是边边角角的跑出来
就知道今天的盘体感温度
非常的不好
但是不好我们之前讲了
管理率大啊
长上去那大家也没办法追啊
那下来又很害怕
不知道该怎么剪
今天我们的救星来了
今天的救星来了
今天我们的来宾
是我们的AI达人蔡明翰
欢迎她
趙华好 觀眾朋友 聽眾朋友 大家好
聽到觀眾朋友就知道
今天這集勢必要有影片版的啦
明翰 就是我已經決定
今天我要全部都讓你講
今天其實國際上面除了三星的財報
是非常好 卻利多不長之外
當然這幾天也圍繞在我們講的
這個延調機構
這個Semi-Aleases
它的報告一直出一直出
從打記憶體 打CPU
打到店員
再接下來打到窄版
同伯基版一起打了
因為他說NV机鬼會延後
可是黃樂迅有出來講
黃樂迅有出來講
沒有啊
沒有這回事
但似乎無力回天
盤面上就是非常的圍繞著一個擔心
到底你覺得
這幾天再跌哪件事情
本來開盤還沒亮
慢慢地跌出一些亮
不過說實話
從上個禮拜一到現在
我們都處於一個
稍微比較低亮的狀態
好 到底發生什麼事
有沒有事情
其實滿容易解釋的因为如果有事 我常常讲有事不会让你开盘让你开红让你跑对不对 其实蛮理解的这个蛮容易理解的就是效率市场应该直接下去
如果真的有事
那你说会不会盘中有事
我说亚洲不会有什么重要的事
那我们大部分都跟美国
美国人在睡觉哪会有什么事情
对 所以其实蛮容易理解
就是人才人
那其实我觉得应该说不容易
应该说很容易推顿这个结果
那结论应该是什么
其實比較明顯的並不是我們開殺的
其實應該最主要關鍵點是因為
昨天的台積電ADR是大幅受壓的
所以台股自然就呈現往上
可是一開盤的時候就看得出來
其實市場那個買多的氣氛
並沒有那麼熱烈
有點被韓股交襲了
因為韓股開低
對 韓股開低
那亞股等於我們在開的時候
有台積電撐盤
那其他人一開始還跟著開高
當時發現就覺得那個氣勢越來越不對
因為韓國股市不斷走弱
那我覺得這個也沒有很意外
因為你有一個問題就是
美光其實已經走在前面給你看
美光說的這麼漂亮
當天有沒有大漲 有
漲超過一層 後面怎麼樣
就一直軟掉 一直往下走
結論就是講得再好
隔天開高的 最近去都是套牢
那今天韓國就直接跳過那個開高
去把人家騙進來那一套
直接就開低了
那我覺得這個結論而言
今天台股就是真的就是韓國股市所拖累
那畢竟常常
今天我在跟人家講這個觀念
人家講說
那這樣了不起影響到台灣記憶體
記憶體也不至於到台股大跌
而且記憶體開盤是紅的
對啊
那他會講說這個好像跟
台灣也沒太大關係
我說沒錯
可是人家韓國股市跌了快5%
難道我們都不影響嗎
不可能
所以一定是跟著這個開低
沒關係 現在問題在哪裡
就是因為漲太多 先殺再說
反正在裡面都賺錢
我怎麼知道會不會連續殺好幾天
我先跑 先入貸為安
然後就會導致人踩人
第一個人賣一賣之後就開始跌
第二個人就跟著進來
所以就會導致賣壓會越來越重
我覺得這是蠻合理的現象
所以結論來講 你先回過頭來
先講到韓國股市
這個到底會不會代表高點已經過了應該說最近記憶體確實有這樣很大的壓力所以廢半 包含韓國股市有出現比較明顯的拉回但是我覺得
簡單而言就今年上半年這個漲幅
不是大家設飛鏢就跟著買的
就是他們真的是獲利
獲利很扎實的提升
應該說結論而言
包含台灣跟韓國
今年的漲幅
結論而言就是股市的漲幅
其实都还不及
获利上修的幅度
这个大概就是
大家有这个概念
就是说获利上修的幅度
其实比股市涨幅更大
你是说记忆体吗
还是说整体
其实我觉得整体
可能要看族群
对不对
有的族群确实是如此
有的族群是有点跟不上
就是获利跟不上涨幅
我讲的整体是从
台湾角度出发
跟韩国角度出发
但是你会说不对
我看很多
对没有错
就是两家
它記憶體拖上去
導致整個韓國
獲利上修的幅度
比韓國的漲幅還要大
那台灣也是一樣
就是這個台積電
今年以來獲利
從70幾塊已經上修
到現在已經突破100了
那台股的獲利上修幅度也很大
那台股呢
其實現在的
應該說或者是講
簡單於光台積電
它的股價漲幅
其實還不如它的獲利漲幅
所以結論而言其實並沒有操長的問題
但是乖離率大
大家自然就會害怕
就會有賣壓
我覺得是很合理的
但是就目前為止
趨勢是沒有改變的
那又回過頭來
投資人常常講
那是不是應該先下車
尤其我們上次才來講說
7月之後搞不好再上去
害怕
可是我個人覺得
等於說第三季的賣壓
其實到目前為止
我觉得还没有真正开始
我觉得这个时间点一定是在台积电法说会之后
台积电法说会之前
就算开杀空间都很有限
因为大家期待的是
最起码要听到这个利多之后
我要杀我再来开杀
我觉得这是很合理的现象
所以理论上不可能在台积电法说前
所以这个震荡拉回是很正常的现象
我个人觉得以今天这个股市的角度
我觉得大家的那个体感温度
跟限时温度有这么大落差
最主要的原因还是卡在第二季的那个熔景之内就是会觉得照一讲就应該每天大漲才合理每天就應該漲一千點怎麼可能會有跌一千點的狀況
那常常我常常講
股市本來就是漲漲跌跌
就目前的角度
根本完全談不上任何空頭的邊緣都沒有
純粹就是漲多震盪而已
那會有這麼大的體感
就是我剛剛提到
卡在第二季的那個感受
应该是要每天往上
那稍微一点拉回
就会觉得压力很大
我觉得
我之前就讲
这种事件要连续三天
所有人才会回到
才会把第二季的融景给忘掉
因为现在的状况
应该说从第二季以来
就是只要有拉回
就是买一点都不害怕
那我个人觉得
这个对台湾投资看起来是正向
但老实讲对盘面不是那么正向
当所有人都觉得台股
绝对不会跌的时候
其实对台股不是好事
你应该要回到
刚刚提到的第一季
或去年就是涨涨跌跌
总有涨总有跌
才是一个比较健康的状态
今年第二季
因为在一季的时间点
就涨了超过一万点
然后中间几乎不休息
然后每一次拉回就闭着眼睛
然后杠杆越开越大
就是越赚越多的代表
这个思维你必须要像今天这种
连续修正三天
整个市场就会回到原本的状态
至于会不会出现
我刚刚提到
我觉得这种事件应该
比较有可能会发生在法朔后
所以我觉得现在的修正
其实不用太紧张
至于刚刚提到的
Seminars之类的
讲到很多的这些鬼故事
其实我觉得这些细节
你会去拆解
会发现老实讲
都没有很大的重点所在
其实只有一个
他讲的各产业我觉得都不重要
因为结论只有一个
因为AI到底结束了没
因为如果AI没有结束
代表所有的人都在同一艘船上
所以大家要往前走
大家都不会脱队
只有一种比较大
比较夸张的可能性举个例好了
就像如果你做散热
以前是从气冷转
艺冷跟气冷合并
到这一次来讲
未来是不会再有气冷
如果你任何公司一直卡在气冷
沒辦法進到藝人
那你確實有可能會被淘汰
但是簡單而言
散熱主權大家的公司
不可能有這種事情
所以理論上
一定会跟上部队
所以只有一种可能性
你最后要觉得未来
会有个比较大幅修正
代表你认为AI已经见顶
可是我觉得AI见顶
这个故事已经两三年来
怎么听都永远都有
但是我觉得很多的数字都告诉你
这个是不可能
短时间来讲是不可能发生的
所以结论就是AI还在持续往上
所以他说讲各个产业
我觉得都不需要去听
唯一一个可能性
他讲的就是有道理的
就是講到他的是不是有可能delay
甚至現在講有可能會delay一年
那其實我們之前在Podcast也提到
我就說其實下半年
唯一要面臨最大的可能性的
的利空
就是最後VeraRubin出來的時間點不如預期
那我那時候也提到 這個概念也很簡單
因為輝達就是每兩年
他就是會改朝換代一次
而且公司的說法一定是講一個
出來那個時間點
因為做生意的人
他在講 他一定是講一個最樂觀
簡單來講就是上萬個零件組起來
他的想法就是
這一上萬個零件是都沒有出狀況的
我會告訴你 下半年會出
就是因為這1萬多個零件
都沒有狀況的情況下
我下半年就可以出貨
可是每一次這麼多東西就不可能
全部都剛好
而且你要知道
中間只要卡一個東西就是出不來
那所以結論而言會發生什麼事
大家回去看一下2022年就知道
反正結論就是當時出不來
其實股市也沒有太大的跌幅
但是確實就是整理了蠻長一段時間
那而且有個特色
中間整理的時間點代表了業績轉弱
答案一點都沒有
因為上一次要進入Blackwell的時候
卡了半年
這半年的場景是就是股市橫向整理
但是業績面
我們看到AI相關主權的營收還在網上
就是新的產品拿不到
但是大家都還在排隊買舊的Hopper
所以這一次來講就是說
他到底是Delay一季兩季三季
還是根本不Delay
我個人覺得根本不重要
反正只要Delay
他你股價就得整理
但是記得一件事情
業績不會受到影響
就是Vero Rubin可能出來的時間會卡關
可是現在的Blackwell的出貨
他還是會持續接上
所以这些个股的业绩并不会往下掉所以你只要看到营收都还在创高它修正的空间就不会太大所以我觉得整个结论就是我个人觉得其他讲的鬼故事
我也懒得去拆解
我觉得根本一点意义都没有
因为你如果各自的产业
我刚刚讲就在同一艘船上
不可能突然告诉你记忆体不要了
也不可能告诉你说散热不要了
或者什么载版不要了
这些我觉得都不合逻辑
反正结论就是所有最后组装成一台
任何东西都是要的
现在唯一可以
我觉得有可能发生的
就是所谓的新产品的delay
但是影响的程度是相对有限
投资人自己就拿捏
如果你真的假设
因为现在连黄元轩都出来说没有
但是跟两年前就有点不同
因为两年前那时候是
那时候的delay的发生现象是
研究員去跑各產業聽回來的消息
所以大家就開始傳delay
可是比較明顯的特色
就是那時候市場傳得沸沸揚揚
可是回答就是不出來講話
所以他現在呢
或說沒有
我認為他講沒有就是真的沒有
但是要有一種可能性
就是假設未來越來越明確了
然後回答就再也不講話了
那就可能像兩年前那個格局
那也許就是一季到兩季的時間
可能会稍有压抑
但记得重点是趋势不会改变
大家要关注的并不是
它什么时候出来
是你看到这些AI属群的营收
是不是持续往上
VeraRubin暂时不出来
不会有太大的影响
但是你如果新产品不出来
但是你旧的不能掉
然后你只要这个架构
跟两年前一样
股市修正的空间
老实讲真的不大
那反而是这些
之前大家要买这种
極優的AI股
那反而是在這個時間點
就是很好的機會
你可以分散一段時間
定期持續扣款
那等到他只要新產品一出來
他自然又回到原本的軌道之上
好 所以其實剛剛明漢的邏輯
從以前到現在
我們錄Podcast那麼多集到現在
邏輯沒有改變
就是AI的前景和這些零組件
到底需不需要
都很需要
那你說有沒有可能回答的機會
有一點延後
其實這不是第一次
常常的是
只要有新產品
甚至他的新產品還有分喔
有的是過渡型產品
有的是正宗一定要推出來的產品這中間有很多細膩的調整當然這一次華人軒是立刻出來說其其實輝達股價也跌了非常多了已經不正好長一段時間了他出來說我們先姑且信之
可是我覺得最重要的一件事情是
我們往往在股市上漲的時候
知道很樂觀
然後就容易看到追
就是漲上去了
我才拼命地把我的成本追在相對比較高
所以一回檔的時候感受很差
其實感受不需要很差
今天雖然大盤到最後是說
今天雖然大盤到最後是破了月線
可是如果你們把大盤的圖拉出來看
就會發現有一點煩啦
怎麼煩
就這一個月它有一點在橫盤
它雖然有上去到48000多點
好像要創新高
可是嚴格來說
它就是在一個橫盤的區間走
所以呢
像我之前不是提到說
國巨賣飛了
什麼信唱店賣飛了
今天他們兩家公司
剛好就回到我賣掉的那個位置
所以它就會有點來回
如果中間沒有去做護理了結
沒有去做所謂適度的停力的人
可能就會覺得我在幹嘛
我在抱上抱下
對 其實我覺得這段時間就是容易這樣
那這段時間要幹嘛呢
我覺得就是第一
耐性還是要拿出來
相信明漢講的
其實趨勢沒有改變
然後第二
盡量不要買在追的位置
當然明漢有講
有一些是業績還沒有很好
可是勢頭很強的
那個追的話
自己要設停力點出場
對 那個不要一直死爆火爆
好 再不然就像我今天
还是做了同样一件事
今天跌1000点
今天破月线
今天有很多的ETF
不但破月线甚至往季线走
我还是照我的惯例
今天做了一些加码
那我在加码的时候也在看
例如就拿981A来说好了
今天有跌到所谓的30块钱以下
我想上次加码好像也是这个钱
29点多
今天又是29点多
等于中间它有上去这段
我如果没有停利就没有
可是那也没有关系
因为你就是在累计
累积你可以接受的部位
台积电也是一样
上去到新高不要追
那下来你是不是还有信心
可以累积一些
我觉得这段时间是考验
明汉讲的
不是一直往右上角去
可能会先整理的时候
如何在比较低的位积和低的成本
累积你可以接受的
股票也好
ETF也好
把你的部位先慢慢地建立起来
或者是讲
我觉得现在这个时间点
我覺得投資人比較重要的關鍵就是
你要稍微分清楚一下
就是說我們之前在節目講的
到底哪一些買黑不買紅哪些是買紅不買黑現在就是必須區分的時候了現在要請民漢區分了對 因為你無論怎樣在上漲的時間點
這個雞犬升天
其實不管怎樣都是對的
當一震盪的時候
故事就不一樣了
然後我們剛剛提到
在震盪的時候
到底你現在拉回可不可以買
其實我覺得這個族群
我們依依點名
到時候有些人就不太高興
其實你自己檢查一下個股就好
你自己的这个
因为现在刚好在公布6月营收
就算没关系
因为毕竟还没有全数公布也无所谓
你如果有办法
你就看到6月的累积营收
如果没有你就看到5月的累积营收
再给大家概念就是上市柜
到5月营收就是累积成长接近三成
我个人觉得
我不见得每个都要到三成
如果能够明显过三成的
甚至我常讲的很多的纯AI股
其实成长5、6成的其实蛮多的
如果你的
你自己持有的個股
營收年增率超過五成以上
你現在拉回一點都不用害怕
甚至你在考慮什麼點要去做加碼
那當然我剛剛講四月以後很多的
相對來講基本面沒那麼強的
其實股價都漲蠻多的
那我剛剛講的產業我們就不予點名
自己檢查你的個股就好
我覺得剛剛講均值在三層
我個人覺得中間可以給一點點的空間
可是如果你的個股連兩層都不到
甚至还个位数的
甚至还有很多是负的
自己去查一下
甚至还有很多到5月的累计营收
都还是负的
可是4 5 6月也是涨到翻的
那这个时间点呢
就必须要稍微
可能它的股价的震荡幅度就会很大
那后续会发生什么现象
我自己觉得就是回过头来
我们前段提到的市场氛围的问题
因为今年的特色呢
就是在上扬的过程当中
拉回就去接
然后它就创高
所以大家都觉得OK
习惯养成
对 习惯养成
那我觉得现在的角度
就以今天体感温度很差
可是大家还好
我觉得这个还不算真的市场
我简单言就我的角度
有没有到恐慌
今天只是感受不舒服
感受不好而已
但是绝对没有到恐慌
没有到大家都在讨论
要怎么跑或跑不掉了
那个离距离那个还蛮远的
因为今天也是慢慢降落
今天不是一开盘刷1000点
然后1800点
我們歷經過這個事
就是慢慢慢慢降落
不可能就是這麼沒效率
對 所以我的意思說
如果氛圍要轉變
像這種情況要聯繫
連續三天 整個市場氛圍就改變
那我就說差別差在哪裡
如果我們剛剛講的就是
買黑不買紅
就是代表基優股拉回的部分就可以買
那你就不用緊張
代表你的這個個股營收
一定要明顯的高過整體均值
就超過三成以上
能夠過比如說五成六成
那這個非常安全
你這段時間你就是看要怎麼買
我們先講那個
就是數字明顯低於均值的
現在要怎麼辦
我剛剛提到
这自己要衡量一下
你会很难去拿捏
因为以今天的角度而言
体管温度不好
但特色就是你可以撑住
因为特色的原因是
如果现在只是还没有恐慌
没有经过恐慌那一段
就是拉回整理两三天之后再过高
那这些族群就有可能会活起来
但是如果经过三天的洗礼
然后市场出现过恐慌
在复苏的情况下
就不会有人再去敢去买
那个数字没那么好
然后呢
就今年第二季很强的
那个就没有人敢买了
所以就会导致这些族群
在反弹之后的
这个状况会非常弱势
而且是没办法过高的
但是你问我说
所以现在是不是该出拖
我老实讲
这个就是很难拿
因为如果等到三天到了之后
你发现趋势翻转
你才砍
那你会砍在非常非常低的位置
因為這個反轉有時候很可怕
當然我先舉個例子 像例如說載板
我說載板反轉
載板其實營收的成長率是有符合
民漢的正向表裂的
但是我剛剛看了一下載板高低點
已經會出現大概25%的跌幅
就幾天而已
對 這個25% 幾天而已
可是我的意思是
所以就是真的不要太慢才去做決定
對 我不知我覺得說差別差在哪裡
就以這個載版
我們就可以做到兩個例子
第一個部分就是
它可以在很短就殺得很快
第一天呢
你會不知道到底要不要殺
等到三天後
你確定市場恐慌要殺
你要殺得下的時候
因為你會痛
所以你可以有幾種情境
第一個呢
就是不太對的時候
其實就該跑
因為我個人覺得
我之前講的就是
買紅不買黑的
其實就是紅的時候就要追
發現不太對勁
我個人就會建議
這種族群就是跑
因为你拉回之后
你其实很难操作那当然另外一种就是我刚刚提到的你跌回三天之后你发现确认市场氛围已经改变了出现恐慌代表之后反弹都不会太高了
那你那个时间点不要砍
你应该要等到反弹
他一定是弱势反弹
但是弱势反弹总比
砍在最低点
所以那个时候你就知道
经过这次洗礼
未来他就是弱势反弹
所以上来你必须要减码
這個是給你
等於說最後一次逃脫的機會
後續來講沒有數字的
可能就會整理相對比較長
那這一塊剛好也是
符合我之前提到的
這個那時候跟趙華聊也是
我是講了一個現象就是
大家從有數字
到數字稍微不好一點點
但還勉強可以知道說
他的獲利是好轉
就舉個例子
我個人覺得卡在中間
就類似被動
就是你說他全部炒作也不是
人家獲利有好轉
但是他獲利好轉的幅度
連均值都不到
大概就是他就是卡在中間
到最後進到主動的時候
就是數字幾乎已經是平的
然後但他股價又更強
因為主動
昨天有跟大家分享
六月營收有出來
就真的還好
是 那我就說
我那上次就講
這個沿路從基優一直到還不錯
一直到都沒數字的時候
其實這就是整個循環的
陌生段
那陌生段我常常講
陌生段不代表一定要下跌
那你最後如果要繼續下去
只有一種機會
就是再把這個棒子
再交回到前段基歐股
因為下來一個循環之後
代表基歐股其實已經休息很久了
甚至他們資金不在他們那裡
甚至他們都已經跌滿久了
也整理了
所以加上法說會陸續來了
所以資金就會再回到原本的基歐股
所以無論如何來講
无论是要嘛就是
把棒子交回到最前面
那不然就是不交棒
可能股市就会压力很大
无论如何本来到后段
对于这种没有数字的族群
本来就应该要提高警觉
我觉得这个是合理的
那我常常讲就是
现这个时间点
大家就是第一件事情
自己手上持股
先把它分一分
就是哪一些是
数字是最起码是高于平均的
那这些切记
你哪怕你不要养成那个习惯
就是每一次要下來要砍的時候
就去檢查你的未實現損益
而不是看那個
每次就砍那個人家那個表現好然後賺錢的就先去砍那個獲利錯你不要去砍不要去看未實現損益你直接看營收的表現營收好的高於均值的留下來
不好的未來一定先砍那個低於均值的
那個才是比較對的一個策略
這一點很重要
其實這點以前是我們做股票
在看營收
或是說它的價值面的一個核心
可是我覺得因為今年以來
實在長太兇了
我覺得很多人會把這東西丟掉
因為會覺得漲得兇的比較厲害
不見得是在這個價值核心
然後在處分股票的時候
很容易就會覺得
這個有賺了啦
我先把這個賣掉
那個套勞的就萬年不賣有沒有
你也不管說這個再漲得
是不是因為營收超級棒
然後那個再跌的是不是因為營收很爛
那明漢是說要回歸到這個初心
就是如果現在一樣是減壓
其實每一次在震盪的時候
我就會覺得說
不管你是說定時的停力也好
或是幫自己減壓也好
你要檢視賣掉什麼樣的股票
應該要有準則
這個準則就是
例如說這檔股票給你很大的壓力
這也是啊
它波動很大
所以你會覺得有賺就走
即使可能會賣飛
然後再來就是
民漢的意思是
如果這檔股票的獲利營收
剛剛講到的
今年累計的營收
根本就跟不上一個均值
這種的你可能也要優先考慮
在減壓的過程中把它處理掉
我覺得是這樣
那當然有人覺得沒壓力
有人覺得他的槓桿要開好開滿
或者他手上現金還很多
那這段時間跌下來有跌
他就去減他要的股票
可以這麼心安理得我覺得也很棒
可惜就是我們遇到的大部分人
比較不是這樣子
而是像今天體感不好
我看到也是很多人就說
怎麼辦 怎麼又這樣
然後尤其是手上
如果像剛剛講到的宰版啦
被動元件的朋友
真的我覺得今天的體感應該非常的差
好 那剛剛有提到
我們要看這個營收成長率
有沒有跟上均值的狀況
那明漢說不要得罪產業
但是我就先正面表列好了
有正面的嘛
正面的像PCB
像设备股
设备股也没有全部
就是有部分有入账的
尤其六月应该是设备股入账的高峰
应该是值得期待
或者是说像有一些半导体的公司
然后还有说像
刚刚其实我觉得像载版类的
他们后面的营收成长率也越来越高
只是载版的缺点是
它的怎么讲
本益比非常高
同伯基板
其实同伯基板缴出来的成绩都非常的漂亮
有一个比较委屈的我觉得是散热
其实散热今年成绩还是好
可是今年股價一直不青睞
我們先從正面表列的來看好了正面表列的例如像台光點上禮拜五結出營收是創歷史新高就昨天沒有用直接被殺到一個跌廳板
今天又被大盤蓋住
怎麼樣來在我剛剛講的正面表列裡面
排出你的優先順序
好 其實剛剛提到的
我們就目前開出來的營收
剛剛幾乎大部分
我覺得比較強勢的
幾乎都有點名到
那我覺得這些還包含機殼
就是AI的一個部分
還有相對來講有一些族群
我覺得表現都不錯
還有這個封測的部分
對 而且特色也是什麼
就是昨天前天的時候
因為營收很好
而且不只一檔
所以整個族群又轉橋
幾乎今天也是很多都被打到給亭
對 所以我自己說
你看 一樣的問題
兩天前因為營收創高
股價創高 結果你敢追
今天呢
一模一樣場景被打到跌停
更便宜 突然不敢買了
這個邏輯就不太對
所以結論而言就是說
那好 我就要講
你在進場的時候
在突破的時候 應該是要適量買
我覺得那個買的人有沒有錯
我個人覺得是沒有錯的
因為他整理過了
然後數字也對了
然後股價也反應突破了
如果是我也會追
所以我覺得是合理
可是養成一個習慣
你進去的時候
其實本來就不應該一次O-In
你應該要把資金分成多比
好 那我就說
可是人家跟我講 我就錯了
我記得錯了也沒關係
這種股票你要抱著
你中間不要
你如果槓桿我就沒辦法
沒有槓桿的
這種股票一定要抱著
你不要管它怎麼殺
不要說昨天很強 今天突然跌停了
你的心態就完全不對
而且我是說數字沒有任何改變
你不要去管市場怎麼去反應它
因為它的數字是對的 產業也對的
股價的位階也都還在合理範圍
所以我覺得這種
尤其是剛剛提到的種族群
都是不用擔心拉回的
那這種震盪比較大
我覺得比較有爭議就是宅版跟CCL
因為他們的伴隨最大的毛病
就是本益比真的很高
對 長了很多很多
結論來講就是你沒見過
降著本益比
或者是漲十倍以上
對 就是真的是沒見過降著本益比
所以震盪幅度是一定很大的
但是我常常講的這個概念就是
這兩年來從24 25
就因為AI伺服器
要他們的這些所謂的產能
絕對不會因為現在突然不要了
所以這個趨勢是不會有任何
那尤其是中間我覺得很多的
結論 我常常講很多的鬼故事
我就一聽就覺得這個不合理
到這種地步 我覺得最主要
如果我覺得雖然我覺得要做到很難
可是這個就是一個必須要學會的課題
就是你覺得這些對或錯
有時候真的不要去看股價
你就是甚至看到這些新聞
你應該在等於說還沒開盤前去想一下
開盤前去想一下這到底利多還利空
那不要因為這個開了之後
看漲就覺得是好像沒事
看跌又很害怕
我剛剛講就是說
各產業的問題
就講到剛剛講的台光電對不對
然後其實營收很好
所以它創高
應該說營收跟獲利都不斷走高
所以帶動股價也往上去試著要突破
結果因為載板的利空
宅版大跌
他也跟著下來
老實講
他們跟這兩個
也沒有太直接的關係
他們的共同點就是
本益比高得非常嚇人
就這樣子而已
但是其實憑良心講
人家營收都還在創歷史新高
那我常常講的
就是昨天一直很多人在問我說
在講到說
這些記憶體廠
三星海力士說要砍宅版的價格
對 這個是上禮拜五的傳聞
对 那时候在讲的这件事情
当然确实三星海力士
确实有这样的一个预期
那我是说到底会结果怎样
根本先不用去预期
你只要先想一件事情就是
这件事情到底应该说
他们今年股价的涨幅
跟这一个利多有没有关系
如果说我举一个例子就是说
今年以来宅板能够大涨
就是因为年初的时候它涨价
然后三星海力士
答应让他们涨价之后
导致他股价涨了这么多
现在三星海一地市突然醒了说
那个涨价的部分
我下半年已经不接受
我们要调回原本的价格
代表着这整个利多已经不存在
那代表今年的涨幅
你应该不要想全数回土
最起码土回三分之二也是合理
但是要记得一件事
你就看一下内容
它说它报价上涨3到4%
这就是你的P是上涨三到四
可是你整个营收其实这个栽办族群大致上他们的成长幅度大概就跟我刚刚提到市场均值差不多接近三成那我刚刚讲他们成长三成
但报价只有上涨三到四
所以很明显的其实是Q的成长
就是量的成长
并不是因为他们调涨价格
换个角度讲
我举一个比较简单的例子
他们的营收是成长三成
如果年初的时候
这个三星海利市是让他们调涨三成
那故事不一樣
因為它是因為報價調漲三成
所以總營收調最後增長了三成
代表這三成如果押回去
他們的營收就會接近零成長
那這個故事就恐怖了
那代表他們跌的是很應該
可是他們成長三成
報價只有漲三道四
代表這三道四假設
萬一被押回來
他們的營收會不會受到影響
會
但是那個幅度真的非常小
通常線他們還是會持續走高
換句話講
如果講到單一產業的利空
就是我講的問題
單一產業利空真的不用管它
因為整個架構還是在同一艘船上
不可能未來不需要載板
現在載板就是很夯
不然不可能給你這麼高的本益比
所以趨勢不會改變
反而近期利空的時候
是一個很好的借入機會
載板其實它的故事
我覺得其實相對具體
怎麼具體
因為像我也很喜歡CPU這樣的產業
可是CPU的故事它相對沒那麼具體
为什么这么讲
因为像CPU它还会有所谓技术上面
到底要往哪一条路发展
像前一阵子康宁说
它有一些新的玻璃桥接技术
可能会取代FAU或什么的
那市场就会吓到
因为我们都不是技术中人
而且再加上他们的普及应用
本来就是未来的事情
所以你会导致觉得中间可能技术测试A测试B
不同的发展路线
那是有可能的
可是载版这个事情
它是已经算是蛮确定的
就是规格上面
只是先用后用
是不是要延后用
量率如何
大概是一个这样的情形
但有一个很现实的是
载板在今年上半年
其实是比较没有缺口问题的
载板的缺口
事实上是要从下半年到明年
它才会有所谓的供需缺口
因为载板在上一波
已经有扩产过了
所以一开始没有缺口
就是跟明翰讲的
它是把它的产能给拉上来了
所以它的产能现在卖得多了
涨价幅度还没有很明显
不过当然景硕有开第一箱
景硕有讲说
下半年他覺得漲價幅度要8個百分點以上
他就把漲價幅度也先拉開然後顏料機構就說2027年栽辦的缺口就會擴大了2028年栽宅版協會擴大了好,是用這樣的想法但是你說有沒有可能的成真性
我覺得當然是有啦
因為他們現在產能就是已經拉上來了嘛
然後需求越來越強
然後下半年漲價幅度也比上半年高
我覺得故事在前進,但本比拉太高
不過也因為是故事在前進的關係
拉回來我確實也覺得
宅版的,他的怎麼講
他的事情還沒有結束啦
就是等籌碼什麼時候再回來去喜歡他
那我覺得要喜歡這個族群人
其實心裡面也要有一個尺
就是他就是本益比非常高
他賣的就是下半年你一定要長得比上半年多
缺口要不斷地放大這件事情
所以他就是要觀察這個
可是如果說是像台光
我覺得至少他找出來已經是非常讚的一個成績
那他可能就是在本益比上稍微再做點修正
大家就會覺得比較合理
就跟前陣在疊那個台達店
那很多人說沒有辦法 台大電很棒
可是本益比漲到50倍
那如果能夠修正回30幾倍呢
40倍呢
可能比較有那個平價的想像空間
我覺得大家會買起來比較安心
對 應該這樣講
我覺得這個趨勢是確定的
但是你比較難去抓準每一個
產業的這個漲勢的節奏
所以我常常講最安全的方式就是
你的資金就是分個四五比五六比
然後在每個族群各買一些
但是我剛剛講資金有限
不要每個族群裡面每個都買
就是什麼台光店 台藥什麼
每一檔都買 全部都卡在CCL
上去的時候你很high
一下來你又是重災區
其實我今天超想買台藥的
然後他一開始也很爭氣
後來又被大盤咕嚕咕嚕壓下去
確實就是今天幾乎全面性的
我的意思說如果你每個族群都有
那你就講啊 就舉個例
就像說剛剛趙海提到
今年散熱就算是
其實基本面沒有任何改變
但是市場就是不青睞
它就是呈現比較落後
我常常講
這個東西也是很合理的現象
就比如說機殼
或者是滑軌族群
其實之前川湖也整理很久
我印象裡就是那時候是
去年到今年
也有人在FB留言問我說
窗戶到底發生什麼事情
對 有很多人問
我說沒有事就純粹是資金不敬因為我不會因為它股價弱而且甚至现行很弱就跟你讲其实它不好因为确实它的财报表现就是很好
但是不见得这么
就是会有办法吸引资金进去
然后到最近终于开始
有稍微活起来了
那我常常讲的
我什么时候会活起来
你问我我也不知道
因为如果以前这个时间点比较容易抓
但是经过两年大涨之后
很多的族群其實都在非常高的本益比
他就會有個問題
他一整理的時間點就會拉得很長
但是有個好處
就是他會從高檔修正
一段時間之後
他就開始休息整理
至於後續要整理多久
其實老實講沒有人知道
但有個好處就是他整理的時間點
因為他有數字支撐
所以他不會一路空投
一路往下 一直往下殺
這個倒不會
他就是一個
就是相對而言你會抱他
你會有個感受不太舒服
就是簡單而言
它就是連指數都不如
就是它基本面好到不可思議
但是它居然股價表現
連大盤都不如
所以你會有一點點抱得不太舒服
可是有個問題
就是你其實長線而言在裡面
只要願意忍耐
哪一個族群再輪長
我剛剛提到
你分散在不同族群
其實只要指數上揚
都有你的這個能夠
你的個股能夠持續往上
往上帶動你的資產
所以我覺得應該用這樣的邏輯
去分散在不同的基優股
而且有個好處
就是你不用
第一 拉回的時候你不用害怕
第二 其實你也不用
常常一直要很關注
目前市場的狀況架構
那如果剛剛提到
比如說如果你這個邏輯
其實有載版或CCO是很合理的
因為它基本面很好
那現在看到這個利空重挫了
也許是你六分之一的資產
那你就是相對來講就忍耐一下
那也不至於讓你這兩天壓力非常大
而且不同的就剛剛提到
因為拉回的過程
你看鬼故事講得多嚴重
其實你不用害怕
因為他們的營收就是很好
CCL的營收每個月都在創高
載版現在出來景碩也是創歷史新高
所以這個講鬼故事歸鬼故事
只要營收能創高
過一段時間
市場自然就會忘記目前的利空
好 其實因為每次都講到分批
可是大家可能
不一定每个人都资金非常的庞大
像我是属于谨慎型的
所以我的资金是慢慢打进来的
我就会一直在强调说
每次破月线
甚至如果它破到季线
以所谓的市值型的ETF
或者是说
我比较信得过的科技型的ETF来说
我都会觉得加码没有什么大的压力
因为一张ETF
你说贵的好
三四万好了
当然你说到那个什么6208
那当然是很贵
因为它一直没有办法分拆
很多人有问我说6208为什么不分拆
6208部分還有他的苦衷
他們也很想分拆
因為你看到別人正二分拆
0050分拆
分拆之後那個
整個市值的規模
反而是長得非常大
收益率長得非常多
還有他的苦衷
哎好有點離體了
但是買有很多的ETV
他可能就是一張
一萬兩萬三萬
所以對我來說用加碼他們
是我覺得壓力真的是比較小的
如果加碼個股
像這一陣子下來
其實我有加碼個股
欸加碼個股說實話
你錢進去的速度就很快喔
那你的壓力就會增加比較多
所以我覺得大家在資金的調配上面
在這段時間
一定要有一個想法
因為明漢剛剛有講
不是一下來就會馬上V轉上去
如果你遇到是一個橫盤整理
甚至整理整理破一下再上來
破一下再上來的時候
你的持股信心跟壓力會突然的倍增
因為我最近收到有很多的訊息
他是在開始跟人家比較整個上半年的績效
即使績效已經很好了
我看到整個上半年就賺90幾%的
有一個還說他上半年賺了140%
可是他看到旁邊的人是賺了好幾倍
是從千萬等級變成億
他覺得他自己整個就是輸得很難過
然後就一直每天都在急急隱隱的找說
我要用什麼方式把他贏回來
但沒有想到一追他馬上就回檔的時候
還把原本賬面上的給虧進去的感受就更差了
所以我們不要讓自己落入到這麼焦慮的狀態
我想上半年大家多少都有賺
所以這段時間如果它陷入了一個比較高檔的震盪
那就是剛剛講到的第一 整理你的個股
第二 學習觀察 營收的動能的狀況
第三 到底資金要怎麼樣來分批的打入
甚至你在場邊觀望一下
我覺得也沒有什麼關係
因為你手上都是個股了
那這些都是我們覺得在這段時間可以來
怎麼講 思考的
應該這樣講
我覺得剛剛趙華講的兩個重點
我覺得可以呼應一下
第一個部分就是這個拉回的時候
稍微做一點加碼
因為我個人覺得這個之前也有投資人在我FB留言他就跟我講說我每一次都講說這個要高持股有信心不下車永遠都抱在那裡
那什麼時候獲利了解
而且他還不是只有這樣講
講講而已
他還有比較精確的計算
告訴我說假設你現在
你現在你可能裡面
可能已經有兩三千萬假設
然後你永遠都抱著
然後他說好就算你好了
有可能年收百萬好了
然後你也都沒什麼花
你一年就只有100萬
那代表著當你出事的時候
那個加碼進去到你的池子裡面
其實那個比例是落差很大的
也不是沒道理
對
他講的
我非常認同他講的
我就是長這個樣子
其實我老實講
我後面在加碼
有點加辛酸的
就是加點意思意思
那你原本的部位比較大
但是我的個性就是
我沒有見到這個棒球賽
AI棒球賽打到尾聲
我是不退場
那你現在覺得是幾局
我個人覺得
我覺得蘇媽講第三局
我覺得是滿合理
我覺得現在三分之一是滿合理的
對 我個人覺得
所以我覺得說不退場
然後確實每一次
我有沒有加碼 有
但是那個幅度比例老實講
真的不高
那為什麼要做這個動作
簡單而言這是貫徹自己的策略
我有一定的標準
就时间到我就该加码
而且有一个问题
就是我长期而言
在那个时间点如果不加码
我会觉得很可惜
虽然说我已经可能
口袋已经没钱了
多少都好
因为我会觉得那个有点送分题
我自己的感受
反正我自己会去拿捏
什么时候该进场
因为我会觉得
当看到那些指标都亮灯的时候
我觉得没进场是不对
因为那是有点送分题
还有一个很重要的问题
在那个情境之下
当我觉得要进场的时候
通常就是大家要往外冲的时候
那那个时间点
尤其是如果你自己的信心不够坚定
那就很麻烦
通常你比较难
你比较难做到什么事都不做
因为这个时间点
如果你不去
你不够信心去加码
通常就是旁边的氛围
就是告诉你应该要减码
应该要跑
那我就觉得应该要加码
这个时间点
简单而言
你只要加码
哪怕加码一两万
你就不会
你既然都在加滿 就不會選擇減
那你一開始
當然你一開始能做這個事情必須我剛剛提到你要對後續的角度各樣場景覺得這個就是拉回在一個範圍之內那你有這個也不是
我常講這個都不是講講故事就可以了
結果我們剛剛提到
簡單而言各產業我是懶得理他
那現在的問題就是
比如說有可能新產品的後續延後
我都有一定的證據
覺得說這就不會有事
所以我自然就有信心
為什麼要加碼
純粹很簡單
我就是不想減
我只要稍微加一點
第一 給自己開心一點
因為我覺得加了就有機會賺錢
另外就是你只要加碼
就不會做減碼
所以把握這樣的一個原則
就是現在的趨勢
我常常講的
我覺得投資人
尤其這一段時間快速上漲
還有一個很大的問題
就是你會跟人家比
就是不管跟
不是只有人
就是你可能跟別人的績效比
你可能跟大盤比
你可能跟自己以前比
反正无论如何
我的感受都讲到
投资是一个
我觉得大家都会觉得说
要的投资就是要投资到
大部分分成两种
一种就是
反正我就是要现在赶快多赚点钱
另外一种的人
就是比较有想法一点
他会说我要投资到我退休那天
希望我能够生活自由
但是我的观念就是
投資其實是投資到你不在的那一天
永遠都在投資
所以時間拉長一點
你不要把那個投資
這一季 這一個月
這兩天的這個波動
看得這麼重要
沒有
投資是幾十年的事情
那你只要這個觀念
你就發現
今天這個小case
因為經過這麼
以前的這麼多次的洗禮
加上未來可能還有幾十年的光景
不要因为今天就受到影响
结论就是回过头来
你还是要知道这个基本面
然后重点是
这个投资不要把时间轴看得太短
然后不需要跟任何人做比较
我觉得记得就是长线
这种所谓的复利的一个累计
自然可以让你的财富不断的往上带
你要看到的是
也许是两年三年五年甚至十年后
你的资产的一个走势
所以短線震盪倒是不用害怕
因為我常常講的就是
當漲的時候你就很害怕買的不夠一跌的時候你又覺得我怎麼我麼時候買這麼多你就不斷在這種中間不斷的心底持續的交戰
我會覺得當時間一拉長
其實中間的震盪
其實都只是一個過程而已
而且投資會有一些盲點
例如說不要跟人家比
有人說今年上半年大盤就漲了70%以上
如果投資報酬率沒有70%以上
就是輸大盤
這是不對的
因為它的算法是從1月1號開始算
就等於是1月1號你買的那一筆
假設是大盤好了
然後到了上半年結束
你那一筆就會變成78報酬率
可是這中間你要有加碼呀
就是說你不可能就是從頭到尾
就是一筆錢報到最後嘛
你一筆錢報到最後
那你當然就是一個大贏家
假設你今天買的不是什麼很稀奇古怪的東西
假設就是買一個市值
但因為中間你本來就會加錢進來
所以你的平均報酬率輸給大盤
是很正常的
我的意思是不要从1月1号报到6月30号是70%
如果中间没有70%
No
你要看的是也许你的资产
你一开始投入假设100万
结果到了年中间的时候
你已经变成200万好了
那即使报酬率不是70%是50%
但是你的总体的获利数字就是拉上来
你没有错过这一波台股的行情
我觉得这个是第一个
然后第二个真的不用跟人家去比
因为别人有他的方法跟他的
甚至讲白一点他的运势
然后他的玄学上的运势
他可能这一段时间
他就是做得特别顺
他随便听名牌也会赚
所以他有他的一套
他的一个运作的逻辑
那反而乱了你的逻辑
本来你很喜欢的一些肌肉股
你觉得不太会动
去换了一些你会心惊胆跳的
就算有赚到钱
其实也不见得很开心
然后再来是
每一个人的人生规划
跟收入的状况
本来就不一样
本业我还是觉得要顾好
就是我有看到有一些焦虑人
我会觉得似乎
您就把一生的财富
堵在这一次台股的多头
会觉得这次多头没有掌握到
好像人生就没有了一样
怎么会这样
这个有点扭曲到
我们还是要在本业上面
有一个所谓的稳定收益进来
这样子你在你的投资上面
起起伏伏的时候
你的压力就不会这么大
而不会把它当成人生唯一的伏木
我现在看到这样的情况
我都会有一点为
为这样的想法的朋友担心
就像我最近被通知
我的新房子要交屋了
本来是2028年上半年
但是現在建商就說
這個2027的下半年可能就會交屋了
那交屋的時候
我自己有對我自己貸款的一些規劃嘛
就像當年為什麼我會買了一些債券
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕